some of the most refreshing beer i've
had is i guess this is a place that i
also highly recommend we're going
outside we're going way outside of tokyo
now uh is in hokkaido uh because how do
you get to hokkaido where do i stay in
hokkaido where do you stay in hokkaido
well i've only stayed near sapporo
actually so
but there are several ways to get to
hokkaido because hokkaido is uh hokkaido
is pretty pretty damn big
by the way is the big island at the top
you should you should go there because
the food is the best and the drink is
the best bat you know you can get that
by train but it's pain in the ass from
tokyo yeah it's like four well i mean
it's like four or five hours and you the
last stop is in hakodate which is oh
yeah
look actually like it's i think like
when i was stuck in hokkaido the price
for the planes was actually cheaper than
the price for this
yeah
but like
like we're talking like if you want to
explore outside of tokyo maybe this is
your second or you know second trip
third trip or maybe you're just such an
adventurer you may want to go out or
maybe yeah exactly maybe your adventure
you want to go out [ __ ]
highly recommend hokkaido oh yeah
sapporo is such a cool [ __ ] city it
is it is bars don't get us something
called genghis khan
yeah [ __ ] awesome dude it's all you
can eat normally sometimes if you're
lucky uh yeah uh lamb
it's like korean barbecue but it's a
million times so because like you're
gonna come home you're gonna come to
japan uh and you're gonna cream your
pants at how [ __ ] good the food is
here and you're like my god this is like
pea cuisine how can it get better they
can't get better and then you go to
hokkaido and you're like
how they improved on perfection and then
hawkeye is like hold my support yeah
yeah i'll give you good food yeah like i
don't know how hokkaido has just like
made
like such good food even better because
all of the best japanese cuisine i've
had has basically come from hokkaido
in hokkaido like the best ramen i've had
his is in sapporo um if you wanna
seafood i've had it's in sapporo yeah of
course the best season i've had is in
sapporo uh if you wanna go if you're in
sapporo and you wanna go just easily
find like a ramen joint just go to ramen
alley um because there's just a bunch of
like different ramen shops there and the
airport up in the airport no in the
airport there is there is no insult oh
yeah yeah there's support there's a
place called rahman ali and i've been
there i've been there a bunch a bunch of
times just to try like the different
kind of ramen stalls um and
it's like that's where i've had the best
ramen i've ever had in japan just like
and like every every every store there
has like a different type of ramen um
and it just they are all [ __ ] amazing
they're all [ __ ] bomb
um
yeah just like hokkaido in general i
think if you're gonna go i i
we do recommend the winter at least i
recommend the winter um because there's
a bunch of snow there looks aesthetic as
[ __ ] winter wonderland yeah it is winter
wonderland that's where the snow
festival was held your plane might get
delayed
that is it forgot that is the one
downside of going to hokkaido uh which
is because it snows a lot you're kind of
playing gacha with your plane like will
will you will your plane take off in
time will it not will it get cancelled
well the entire airport shut down uh
yeah the fight find out find out when
you basically go because you can never
really plan around that unfortunately so
you can go to nissiko which is in my
opinion one of the best ski resorts in
japan yeah yeah which is where we went
it's [ __ ] great east coast is amazing
yeah it'll probably be rammed with
tourists oh yeah
i mean it's amazing though yeah really
good food i mean like i feel like i've
only been on two ski resorts now in
japan and nisiko is the superior one but
also it is very foreigner friendly yes
so much so that you might have you might
encounter more foreigners than you will
japanese people it's it's all aussies
yeah it's all aussies it it is all
awesome but then again that's that's
almost all ski resorts in japan it's
just like aussies
let's get that really good area really
really good well i've never been to
hakadate though what's that like i
thought it was chill i love
you go there super early in the morning
and you get literally the catch that
they caught a couple of hours prior wow
and it is it's amazing in my opinion the
best [ __ ] seafood i've had yeah i
think even though the seafood is amazing
in al-qaeda yeah i have to say and how
about it
it was the best next level right so good
so it's also a really small like kind of
quaint little town as well um you can
get around very easily with like the
tram system that they have yeah um
that's what that's what we do you can
walk a lot around a lot of the center
though you can you can but you can also
go to like kind of the nearby uh
mountains as well and get like a really
nice view of hakodate during the night
um yeah really nice would you reckon guy
where director people would get the
seafood does any restaurant or do you
want to do honestly yeah yeah i mean
it's all decent yeah even like the
hundred yen sushi places uh
really solid yeah because the thing is
like even if you go to a big chain
especially like the conveyor belt sushis
um
because
because the uh obviously the ingredients
are locally sourced like just because
even if you go to the same sushi chain
that you might have been to in tokyo it
will taste entirely different to another
sushi to the same sushi chain that you
have in you know in another place
yeah so like even if you go to like a
conveyor sushi uh don't expect that it
will taste exactly the same in tokyo as
it will in another place you go to
because i've had the ex i've had that
exact experience where i'm just like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't realize that
the quality could differ this much with
the same chain oh yeah you think you go
to mcdonald's you get like most of the
time get the same experience every time
but yeah with sushi chains it's just you
it's wildly different depending no well
not wildly because every the baseline is
good right yeah the baseline is good it
it goes it goes from good to [ __ ]
incredible yeah it's what i'm trying to
say here i've never had food poisoning
from fish here it's always been sausages
so
let's take that as scientific 100 proof
yeah
it's not even chicken sashimi or chicken
it's the goddamn sausage
yeah i think i've like one
one thing you don't you need to take an
account into account is that it's
actually like it's a lot harder than you
think to get from hakadate to sapporo if
you want to explore all of hokkaido it's
right i'd say it's practically
impossible to explore all of hokkaido
because it's just so massive those two
it's really fun i really recommend it
some really cool towns like toyota it's
really cool
nice yeah like the best supercar i've
ever had in my life it's in toyoko it's
so good yeah because like the i think i
think the drive between hakodate and
sapporo is like four hours or something
three to four hours three to four hours
even with the train and which is two
hours with europe yeah and most of the
time it's just you're going through the
mountains yeah which is really weird
because like it
you you can really get tricked by the
map right because you you go on google
maps and you go tokyo to hakadate which
is like which is like that and it's like
three hours or four hours with the
shinkansen and then
by the way huh it's not enough
the shinkansen stops at hakodate oh okay
okay no no no yeah yeah yeah two two
haka data it stops a haka data right so
it's like three hours so he's like oh
okay that's not too bad and then uh you
you're like okay maybe i can explore
sapporo as well because it's just over
just there it's just right next to
hakadate and then you google hakadate to
sapporo and it's like four hours four
and a half hours to get like to get like
that distance and you're like what how
does this make sense so uh yeah that's
something to keep in mind which is uh
it's a lot harder to explore all of
hokkaido than it may initially seem it's
i think it's because when you're on the
mainland japan you're so used to like
everything being so much smaller like
all the prefectures are way smaller all
the towns are more likely they're just
easy to get to easily to get to easier
and then you realize that hokkaido in
terms of prefectures is like
so much insanely larger than the next
biggest prefecture in japan that you
kind of forget that like oh yeah this
place is [ __ ] massive
right it's like impossible to get around
yeah